[Music]
it's easy to take for granted how seeing
things in color makes them more exciting
more alive but this boring your eyes are
likely glazing over right about now and
you probably want to click away that's
what happens when you take the color out
of everything good some would say I'm
living with a smartphone addiction I
[Music]
would say I'm just living but yes over
the last couple weeks I've decided to
take some steps to do something about
this problem I've decided to make my
phone well kind of suck I put my iPhone
in greyscale and kept it that way for a
week I was like the iPhone and newsprint
I bet that smokes blue the first day was
was not good Instagram looks like my
grandmother's photo album YouTube was
like just Charlie Chaplin videos
everywhere it's kind of a funny story
how I got here a couple of months ago I
started testing apples screen time which
is a part of its new iOS 12 operating
system which is coming out in the coming
weeks and lets you set all these sorts
of limits about how much time you use
your phone and which apps and it tells
you all about the time you're on your
phone I set some limits but yeah I
ignored those off so I decided I needed
to take a bigger step and I decided to
go see dr. David Greenfield an internet
psychologist and one of the things he
suggested was to try greyscale I think
it will help reduce the amount you tap
on certain apps because those apps are
going to be less appealing to you and if
something is less appealing it'll be
less pleasurable therefore less dopamine
so the idea is is that it'll be less
habit-forming or less addictive
by day two I was definitely checking my
phone last but even better than that was
that I wasn't checking Instagram or
Twitter as compulsively as I usually do
and if I did go into the feeds I were
just so boring that I would want to do
something else like literally anything
else that's why it's really frustrating
that Apple didn't put this in screen
time Google's well-being controls for
the newest version of Android which
pretty much no one has yet automatically
switches to grayscale at the end of the
day yes so Apple buries the grayscale
setting deep in here you have to go to
Settings General accessibility display
accommodations flick on color filters
and then grayscale on Wednesday morning
I was playing with my son before
breakfast but then I wanted to take a
photo of him naturally being the cutest
kid in the world and it was hard to tell
what I was actually capturing through
the black-and-white viewfinder but
there's actually a good trick back in
those accessibility settings if you can
find those again you can program the
button on the side of the iPhone to
launch color filters Wow
it's it's beautiful the blue and the
Twitter it's like I smoked a Crayola
crayon so I've decided I'm going to go
gray when I really want to enforce my
limits and I think that's gonna be a
good chunk of my day it's just been way
more effective for me than Apple's easy
to override screen time limits it's like
trying to put a lock on a cigarette pack
but for now this is helping me look up
from my phone and discover all the color
in my real world
[Music]